before I begin my statement perhaps we
should all recall the continuing
suffering of innocent people in Iraq and
those who have been killed and injured
in terrorist attacks including the
latest horrific attack last Sunday which
killed more than 250 people we were
appointed to consider the UK's policy on
Iraq from 2001 to 2009 and to identify
lessons for the future our report will
be published on the inquiries website
after I finished speaking in 2003 for
the first time since the Second World
War the United Kingdom took part in an
invasion and full-scale occupation of a
sovereign state that was a decision of
the utmost gravity Saddam Hussein was
undoubtedly a brutal dictator who would
attack tear arks neighbors repressed and
killed many of his own people and was in
violation of obligations imposed by the
UN Security Council but the questions
for the inquiry were whether it was
right and necessary to invade Iraq in
March 2003 and whether the UK could and
should have been better prepared for
what followed we have concluded that the
UK chose to join the invasion of Iraq
before the peaceful options for
disarmament had been exhausted military
action at that time was not a last
resort
we have also concluded that the
judgments about the severity of the
threat posed by Iraq's weapons of mass
destruction WMD were presented with a
certainty that was not justified despite
explicit warnings the consequences of
the invasion were underestimated the
planning and preparations for Iraq after
Saddam Hussein were wholly inadequate
the government failed to achieve its
stated objectives I want now to set out
some of the key points in the report
first the formal decision to invade Iraq
if Saddam did not accept the u.s.
ultimatum to leave Iraq within 48 hours
was taken by cabinet on March the 17th
2003 Parliament voted the following day
to support the decision the decision was
however shaped by key choices made by
mr. Blair's government over the previous
18 months which I will now briefly set
out after the attacks on September the
11th 2001 mr. Blair urged President Bush
not to take hasty action on Iraq by
early December u.s. policy had begun to
shift and mr. Blair suggested that the
US and the UK
should work on what he described as a
clever strategy for regime change in
Iraq which would build over time when Mr
Blair met President Bush at Crawford
Texas in early April 2002 the formal
policy was still to contain saddam
hussein but by then there had been a
profound change in the uk's thinking the
Joint Intelligence Committee had
concluded that Saddam Hussein could not
be removed without an invasion the
government was stating that Iraq was a
threat that had to be dealt with it had
to disarm or be disarmed and that
implied the use of force if Iraq did not
comply an internal contingency planning
for a large contribution to a military
invasion had begun at Crawford Mr Blair
sought a partnership as a way of
influencing President Bush he proposed a
un ultimatum to
to readmit inspectors or face the
consequences on July the 28th Mr Blair
wrote to President Bush with an
assurance that he would be with him
whatever but if the US wanted a
coalition for military action changes
would be needed in three key areas
these were progress on the Middle East
peace process UN Authority and a shift
in public opinion in the UK Europe and
the Arab world mr. Blair also pointed
out that there would be a need to commit
to Iraq for the long term subsequently
mr. Blair and mr. straw urged the u.s.
to take the issue of Iraq back to the UN
on September the 7th President Bush
decided to do so on November the 8th
resolution 1441 was adopted unanimously
by the Security Council
it gave Iraq a final opportunity to
disarm or face serious consequences and
it provided for any further breaches by
Iraq to be reported to the Security
Council for assessment the weapons
inspectors returned to Iraq later that
month during December however President
Bush decided that inspectors would not
achieve the desired result the and the
US would take military action in early
2003 at the end of January Mr Blair
accepted the u.s. timetable for military
action by mid-march having also
concluded that the likelihood was war to
help mr. Blair
President Bush agreed to seek a further
UN resolution the second resolution
determining that Iraq had failed to take
its final opportunity to comply with its
obligations
by March the 12th it was clear that
there was no chance of securing majority
support for a second resolution before
the US took military action without
evidence of major new Iraqi violations
all reports from the inspectors that
Iraq was failing to cooperate and they
could not carry out their tasks most
members of the Security Council could
not be convinced that peaceful options
to disarm Iraq had been exhausted and
that military action was therefore
justified Mr Blair and mr. straw blamed
France for the armed pass in the UN and
claimed that the UK government was
acting on behalf of the international
community to uphold the authority of the
Security Council in the absence of a
majority in support of military action
we consider that the UK was in fact
undermining the Security Council's
authority second the inquiry has not
expressed a view on whether military
action was legal that could of course
only be resolved by a properly
constituted and internationally
recognised Court we have however
concluded that the circumstances in
which it was decided that the was a
legal basis for UK military action were
far from satisfactory in mid-january
2003 Lord Goldsmith told Mr Blair that a
further Security Council resolution
would be necessary to provide a legal
basis for military action he did not
advise number 10 until the end of
February that while a second resolution
would be preferable a reasonable case
could be made that resolution 1441 was
sufficient he set that out he set that
view out in written advice on March the
7th the military and the civil service
both asked for more clarity
on whether force would be legal lord
goldsmith then advised that the better
view was that there was on balance a
secure legal basis for military action
without the further Security Council
resolution on March the 14th he asked Mr
Blair to confirm that Iraq had committed
further material breaches as specified
in resolution 1441 Mr Blair did so the
next day however the precise basis on
which mr. Blair made that decision is
not clear given the gravity of the
decision Lord Goldsmith's should have
been asked to provide written advice
explaining how in the absence of a
majority in the Security Council mr.
Blair could take that decision this is
one of a number of occasions identified
by the inquiry when policy should have
been considered by a Cabinet Committee
and then discussed by cabinet itself
third I want to address the assessments
of Iraq's weapons of mass destruction
and how they were presented to support
the case for action there was an
ingrained belief in the UK policy and
intelligence communities that Iraq had
retained some chemical and biological
capabilities was determined to preserve
and if possible enhanced them and in the
future to acquire a nuclear capability
and was able to conceal its activities
from the UN inspectors in the House of
Commons on September the 24th 2002 Mr
Blair presented Iraq's past current and
future capabilities as evidence of the
security severity of the potential
threat from Iraq WMD he said that at
some point in the future that threat
would become a reality the judgments
about Iran's capabilities in that
statement and in the dossier published
the same day were presented with a
certainty that was not justified the
Joint Intelligence Committee should have
made clear to mr. Blair that the
assessed intelligence had not
established beyond doubt either that
Iraq had continued to produce chemical
and biological weapons or that efforts
to develop nuclear weapons continued the
committee has also judged that as long
as sanctions remained effective Iraq
could not develop a nuclear weapon and
that it would take several years to
develop and deploy long-range missiles
in the House of Commons on March the
18th 2003
Mr Blair stated that he judged the
possibility of terrorist groups in
possession of WMD was a real and present
danger to Britain and its national
security and that the threat from Saddam
Hussein's arsenal could not be contained
and posed a clear danger to British
citizens mr. Blair had been warned
however that military action would
increase the threat from al-qaeda to the
UK and UK interests he had also been
warned that an invasion might lead to
Iraq's weapons and capabilities being
transferred into the hands of terrorists
the government's strategy reflected its
confidence in the joint intelligence
committees assessments those assessments
provided the benchmark against which
O'Rourke's conduct and denials and the
reports of the inspectors were judged as
late as March the 17th 2003 mr. Blair
was being advised by the chairman of the
Joint Intelligence Committee that Iraq
possessed chemical and biological
weapons the means to deliver them and
the capacity to produce them he was also
told
that the evidence pointed to saddam
hussein's view that the capability was
militarily significant and his
determination left to his own devices to
build it up further it is now clear that
policy on Iraq was made on the basis of
flawed intelligence and assessments they
were not challenged and they should have
been the findings on Iraq's WMD
capabilities set out in the report of
the Iraq survey group in October 2004
were significant but they did not
support pre-invasion statements by the
UK government which had focused on
Iran's current capabilities which mr.
Blair and mr. straw had described as
vast stocks and an urgent and growing
threat in response to those findings mr.
Blair told the House of Commons that
although Iraq might not have had
stockpiles of actually deployable
weapons Saddam Hussein retained the
intent and the capability and was in
breach of the United Nations obligations
that was not however the explanation for
military action he had given before the
conflict in our report we have
identified a number of lessons to inform
the way in which intelligence may be
used publicly for in the future to
support government policy fourth I want
to address the shortcomings in planning
and preparation the British military
contribution was not settled and
to hoon agreed the military's proposals
for an increase in the number of
brigades to be deployed and that they
would operate in southern not northern
Iraq there was little time to prepare
three brigades and the risks were
neither properly identified nor fully
exposed to ministers the resulting
equipment shortfalls are addressed in
the report despite promises that cabinet
would discuss the military contribution
it did not discuss the military options
or their implications in early January
2003 when the government published its
objectives for post-conflict Iraq it
intended that the interim post-conflict
administration should be UN led by March
2003 having failed to persuade the u.s.
of the advantages of a un-led
administration the government had set
the less ambitious goal of persuading
the us to accept UN authorization of a
coalition LED interim administration
when the invasion began UK policy rested
on an assumption that there would be a
well-executed us-led and UN authorized
operation in a relatively benign
security environment Mr Blair told the
inquiry that the difficulties
encountered in Iraq after the invasion
could not have been known in advance we
do not agree that hindsight is required
the risks of internal strife in Iraq
active Iranian pursuit of its interests
regional instability and al-qaeda
activity in Iraq were each explicitly
identified before the invasion ministers
were aware of the inadequacy of u.s.
plans and concerned about the inability
to exert significant influence
on us planning mr. Blair eventually
succeeded only in the narrow goal of
securing president bush's agreement that
there should be UN authorization of the
post-conflict role furthermore he did
not establish clear ministerial
oversight of UK planning and preparation
he did not ensure that there was a
flexible realistic and fully resourced
plan that integrated UK military and
civilian contributions and addressed the
known risks the failures in the planning
and preparations continued to have an
effect after the invasion that brings me
to the government's failure to achieve
the objectives it had set itself in Iraq
the armed forces fought a successful
military campaign which took Basra and
helped to achieve the departure of
Saddam Hussein and the fall of Baghdad
in less than a month service personnel
civilians who deployed to Iraq and
Iraqis who worked for the UK showed
great courage in the face of
considerable risks and they deserve our
gratitude and respect more than 200
British citizens died as a result of a
conflict in Iraq many more were injured
this has meant deep anguish for many
families including those who are here
today the invasion and subsequent
instability in Iraq had by July 2009
also resulted in the deaths of at least
150,000 Iraqis and probably many more
most of them civilians more than a
million people were displaced the people
of Iraq
have suffered greatly the vision for
Iraq and its people issued by the US the
UK Spain and Portugal at the azores
summit on March the 16th 2003 included a
solemn obligation to help the Iraq
people build a new Iraq at peace with
itself and its neighbors the declaration
looked forward to a united Iraq in which
its people would enjoy security freedom
prosperity and equality with a
government that would uphold human
rights and the rule of law as
cornerstones of democracy we have
considered the post-conflict period in
Iraq in great detail including efforts
to reconstruct the country and to
rebuild the security services and in
this short statement I can only address
a few key points after the invasion the
UK and the u.s. became joint occupying
powers for the year that followed Iraq
was governed by the Coalition
Provisional Authority the UK was fully
implicated in the authority's decisions
but struggled to have a decisive effect
on its policies the government's
preparations failed to take account of
the magnitude of the task of stabilizing
administering and reconstructing Iraq
and of the responsibilities which were
likely to fall to the UK the UK took
particular responsibility for four
provinces in the southeast it did so
without a formal ministerial decision
and without ensuring that it had the
necessary military and civilian
capabilities to discharge its
obligations including crucially to
provide security the scale of the UK
effort in post-conflict Iraq never
matched
the scale of the challenge Whitehall
departments and their ministers failed
to put collective weight behind the task
in practice the UK's most consistent
strategic objective in relation to Iraq
was to reduce the level of its deployed
forces the security situation in both
Baghdad and the southeast began to
deteriorate
soon after the invasion we have found
that the Ministry of Defence was slow in
responding to the threat from improvised
explosive devices and that delays in
providing adequate medium-weight
protected patrol vehicles should not
have been tolerated it is not clear
which person or department within the
Ministry of Defence was responsible for
identifying and articulating such
capability gaps that it should have been
from 2006 the UK military was conducting
two enduring campaigns in Iraq and
Afghanistan it did not have sufficient
resources to do so
decisions on resources for Iraq were
affected by the demands of the operation
in Afghanistan for example the
deployment to Afghanistan had a material
impact on the availability of essential
equipment in Iraq particularly
helicopters and equipment for
surveillance and intelligence collection
by 2007 militia dominance in Basra which
UK commanders were unable to challenge
led to the US UK exchanging detainee
releases for an end to the targeting of
its forces
it was humiliating that the UK reached a
position in which an agreement with a
militia group which had been actively
targeting UK forces was considered the
best option available the UK military
role in Iraq ended a very long way from
success we have sought to set out the
government's actions on Iraq fully and
impartially the evidence is there for
all to see it is an account of an
intervention which went badly wrong
with consequences to this day the
enquiry report is the committee's
unanimous view military action in Iraq
might have been necessary at some point
but in March 2003 there was no imminent
threat from Saddam Hussein the strategy
of containment could have been adapted
and continued for some time the majority
of the Security Council supported
continuing UN inspections and monitoring
military intervention elsewhere may be
required in the future a vital purpose
of the inquiry is to identify what
lessons should be learned from
experience in Iraq there are many
lessons set out in the report some are
about the management of relations with
allies especially the u.s. mr. Blair
overestimated his ability to influence
US decisions on Iraq the UK's
relationship with the US has proved
strong enough over time to bear the
weight of honest disagreement it does
not require unconditional support where
our interests or judgments differ the
lessons also include the importance of
collective ministerial discussion which
encourages frank an informed debate and
challenge the need to assess risks weigh
options
and set an achievable and realistic
strategy the vital role of ministerial
leadership and coordination of action
across government supported by senior
officials the need to ensure that both
civilian and military arms of government
are properly equipped for their tasks
above all the lesson is that all aspects
of any intervention need to be
calculated debated and challenged with
the utmost rigor and when decisions have
been made they need to be implemented
fully sadly neither was the case in
relation to the UK government's actions
in Iraq to conclude I should like to
thank my colleagues our advisers and the
inquiry Secretariat for their commitment
to this difficult task I also want to
pay tribute to Sir Martin Gilbert who
died last year as one of the preeminent
historians of the past century he
brought a unique perspective to our work
and until he became ill in April 2012 we
have missed him greatly as a colleague
and a friend thank you